all right you guys so I gotta hop into
it how are you feeling you know after
the success of season one you know what
were the feelings going into season two
I am so excited to finally actually see
it be released to the world
um and I'm actually when I was going to
season two I mean I was so excited
because season one was
so incredible like absolutely
spectacular and I couldn't wait to now
like change up the whole thing and work
with kids so it'd be a great learning
experience and I've never worked with
like such a big group of kids my age
before so it I was so excited going into
it so cool and what about you naletti
yes same like because at the beginning
of um season one and that was like a
great experience it was so fun I was
with Dania who plays Amy my mom on the
show she was like so knowledgeable
honestly such like a great personality
and then I got to meet my hybrid family
and got to meet Gus
um who Christian plays
and it was just great to have like a ton
of kids around like Christian was saying
like and I'm just really excited for you
guys to see season two I I gotta talk
about how fun it was to see all the
different types of hybrids in this
season and I want to know if you could
be one kind of hybrid what would you be
let's start with you naletti
that's so hard like I know honestly I
love being like one being like a pig
look I feel like it would be cool with
water like a water hybrid you know what
I mean yes
um
okay
like a narwhal I don't know oh
I'm just gonna walk you around with like
a little that would be so cool that
would be so cool if I get in the way of
some things but it'd be so cool what
about you Christian okay so of course I
love being a deer
um I like to choose any other one this
one is actually so Random
but I I'd like to be an armadillo or a
cheetah
what okay wait those are two completely
different ones
because armadillos you see they have
like the strongest shells in the game
well some of the strongest cells and I
love how they they just like can dig on
the ground they they're like really
fascinating scurrying around and stuff
but I also really like cheetahs because
they can run so fast and they're stupid
so you know probably probably I'm gonna
start with cheetah here but as a second
unique option in armadillo I like that I
like these options these are all great
options all right listen I gotta ask you
both because I know last season you got
to talk to Robert Downey Jr via FaceTime
but I gotta know did you finally meet
him in real life
no sadly
but it would have been such an honor
though
um I'm very glad that we got a minimum
FaceTime though yeah that was very
relaxful I was incredible well listen
y'all I gotta say congrats to each of
you on season two I watched it I got
goosebumps it was good y'all are so good
in this and clearly I'm not the only one
that thinks that because you have
received so much Acclaim so much so that
none so you actually received an Emmy
thank you very much thank you very much
you're welcome so listen I gotta know
what is the success meant to y'all
that's any questions
you know what you always get so so
surprised when
um I was saying earlier you never know
what quite is going to make a hit
um show and it's going to be successful
you know and you know to get one here is
is lucky but to get you know two seasons
in a row like this is just amazing and
um I think they've they've done it you
know I think we've we've just got the
right ingredients you can't ever really
I don't think anybody really ever knows
what it is that makes something so
magical work but it seems to have the
right ingredients you know Dania a deal
are just fantastic people to work with
and they bring just so much magic and
talent and their their own experience
and and and also the the cast is so
amazing to work with like everybody is
so respectful and so fun it's actually
fun to come to work in the morning you
know this is a beautiful experience
I was going to say you know the early
like also the relationships that we've
been able to build with one another you
know you can have you know work on on an
amazing show or show the people watch
but those relationships are not really
solid and we genuinely love each other
respect each other like look up to each
other and that that translates on film
and it's not just us I mean it's like
literally the crew the people that are
you know the the production designer the
custom designer the the cinematographer
Everything Has Come Together in you know
in this beautiful pot and it's just a
beautiful dish to to be able to be a
part of and hopefully you guys enjoy it
well I have to ask you know Dania it was
really fun to see all the different
types of hybrids this season I gotta ask
actually I want to ask all of y'all but
I'll start with Donya if you could be a
hybrid what hybrid would you be uh I
said this before I'll tell you a cheetah
she's already a hybrid but I love I love
how fast the cheetah is like thickened
it is and um you know that actually a
cheetah has never attacked a human in um
in the wild so I I think I feel like
there's something really loving about
that animal
mm-hmm it's like fast but you know it
has the ability but it doesn't you know
guys chooses yeah I get it and non-so
what about you I'd be a lion I'd be a
lion I've always I don't know I think in
the jungle and all that kind of thing
yeah yeah I've always chosen that I am
either I like that and a deal what about
you you'll have to go with my original
answer when we were asked before and
that's an otter
oh because I I like the way they look
they're good swimmers and they build
um dams oh I like this